we are now in a recession we are
officially in a recession the second
quarter gdp numbers have come out we've
got two consecutive quarters of negative
gdp growth the white house has asked
about this
this is just before the numbers come out
they're asked about their attempt to
redefine
recession
and what do they do
they redefine
redefining
if things are going so great though then
why is it the white house officials are
trying to redefine recession no we're
not redefining recession if we all
understand a recession to be two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth in a row and then you have white
house officials come up here to say no
no that's not what a recession is it's
something else how is that not
redefining recession because that's not
the definition
that is not the definition
said in 2008 of course
economists have a technical definition
which is of a recession which is two
consecutive quarters
of negative growth
i can tell you this they said two
consecutive two negative quarters of gdp
growth is not the technical definition
of recession
it is not why did he say that it is not
i can i can speak to i can speak to you
to what he said yesterday in front of
all of you which is the last thing that
you just repeated
there are many factors there are many
factors economic factors and indicators
to consider
and
i will say that the textbook definition
of recession is not is not two negative
quarters of gdp
i will not i will not speak to la la la
la la korean shampoo or white house
spokesman
i will not acknowledge what the national
economic council chairman said in 2008 i
will not i will ignore that i will only
speak to what he said yesterday because
oceania is at war with east asia oceania
has always been at war with east asia
that's their story and they're sticking
to it
peter ducey brings the receipts to the
white house
peter ducey
the reporter in in the white house press
pool he shows up to the briefing room
and he says we're in a recession right
or we're about to be officially in a
recession and corrine jean-pierre says
no we're not in a recession he goes why
are you redefining recession she goes
we're not redefining recession recession
is not
two consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth and the person she cites is brian
deese who's the director of the white
house national economic council brian
dees has been going on tv going to the
white house saying that the actual
technical definition of a recession is
not two consecutive quarters of negative
gdp growth which was news to all of us
because if you ever took an economics
class if you ever opened up a dictionary
if you open up a dictionary today you
will find that the technical definition
of a recession is two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth but then
i had i was second guessing myself i was
being successfully gaslit by the white
house because i thought huh i don't know
i'm not an economist maybe i'm just
wrong about this
and then peter ducey says wait a second
in 2008
this same man
this very same director of the national
economic council brian dees said
verbatim the technical definition
economists have a technical definition
of recession which is two consecutive
quarters of negative gdp growth oh okay
i guess we're just being gaslit then
right and
because ducey brought the receipts
karine jean-pierre had nothing to say
and she her actual answer is i'm not
going to talk about that
i'm not going to acknowledge what he
said i'm not going to acknowledge the
dictionary i'm not going to acknowledge
the economics textbooks the definition
of a recession is whatever i want it to
be or whatever joe biden says it is
but that is not the case words do have
meaning
there is
a a reality to the economy and we are
now officially in a recession
biden can keep lying about it all he
wants
just like the libs can say that a man is
actually a woman or the libs can say
that a baby's not a baby and the libs
are going to try to say that a recession
is not a recession but it is we are
officially in a recession and joe
biden's lies are not going to make it
any easier on your wallet ron desantis
obviously wants to challenge
president trump in 2024
and desantis has some real advantages
here he's got some trump has some real
advantages he's super famous he's
hilarious he's a celebrity he was
already the president he's got a lot of
support he's got a lot of advantages
desantis has some advantages too though
desantis is young
he's new
and novelty can be very helpful in
politics and he is full of energy he is
also saying all the right things
we are taking a stand and these bills
i'm signing into law today foreign
adversaries will not have access to our
schools government and companies like
they have in the past in fact the first
bill that i signed today safeguards our
public institutions from undue foreign
foreign influence and that means
prohibiting agreements
between public entities and the
communist party of china or cuba or any
of these other malignant forces as of
the time we sign this bill and it goes
into effect
florida we will be banning things like
confucius institutions from being in our
universities or in our colleges and i
know we had issues with that right here
in in miami-dade counties we're also
going to sign the combating corporate
espionage in florida act it creates new
criminal offenses in florida for the
theft and trafficking of trade secrets
[Music]
[Applause]
this is really good stuff the policy is
really good we do need to kick out this
foreign influence especially chinese
influence
something that desantis is
honing in on which is something that
trump really honed in on which is
something that scandalized virtually
every other republican
in 2016 and almost all the republicans
at the national level is
they realize that we need to wield state
power
we don't need to become tyrannical we
don't need to become dictators we don't
need to wield state power capriciously
or arbitrarily but conservatives when we
get power we need to use it justly we
need to use the power that the people
give us to do good things and improve
people's lives
for a long time for
decades in the conservative movement
republican politicians have have
repeated libertarian slogans to avoid
doing their jobs
i said well you know if we gosh if we
regulate google we'll be just like the
leftists oh we can't do they would be
very wrong to wield the state to stop
drag queen perverts from jiggling for
little kids oh no we can't that would
make us no different from the leftists
if we ever used any government power at
all no no the founding fathers hated the
idea of law and order and justice no
what are you talking about that's just
completely made up
it's it's a political
joke it's a farce that was pushed by
largely by big corporations that just
wanted less regulation and it was pushed
by
libertarians who
as a percentage of the electorate are a
very very small percentage and who who
have an outsized influence or have had
an outside influence in the conservative
movement but don't actually represent a
large portion of the american voting
base and it it represents an idea
that actually does not have a lot of
grounding in american history
and it represents an idea that
politically is just completely
impractical
is going to flow to the people who are
willing to use it and the institutions
that are willing to use it that's a
basic law of politics and so if the
republicans get elected and say elect me
i'm not going to do anything then you're
just seating the entire culture to the
left and then i have to ask why am i
even voting for you
why would i i vote for the republican he
does nothing i vote for the democrat he
does something but i vote for the
republican and the democrats going to do
something anyway so what's the
difference there's no reason and what
desantis and what trump and some other
people too you're seeing a little bit in
the senate from senator cruz from uh
josh hawley a little bit you're seeing
this movement among conservatives now to
say wait no we we can keep boys out of
the girls room we can ban drag queen
story hour we can shut down certain
chinese goods i know maybe it'll hurt
gdp a little bit but this is a national
security threat now we can keep chinese
communist influence out of our schools
we can say no we can wield the power
justly the founding fathers were very
well aware of that every sane person in
our country was aware of that
until very very recently i'm so glad
that you like that clip you know we just
hit one
million
subscribers here on youtube thank you to
everyone who made that happen
let's push it up even higher next goal
one billion so please subscribe like
ring the bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you